[Music]  you think you can fix me Jean you are  not broken  [Music]  beautiful friend behind there's a  fragile thing takes only the slightest  tap to tip it in the wrong direction  Charles what did you do I had to keep a  stable I protected her from the truth  there's another word for that I came  looking for answers you feel like you  don't belong here you don't they can't  begin to comprehend what you are  she's changing  that's what you didn't come here looking  for answers we came here looking for  permission  she's in range  hey that's war coming out of us  gene lost control if she still are fed  this is your fault Charles the world is  on the brink I'm sorry I didn't stop it  Sumer you're always sorry Charles  and as always a speech and nobody cares  they're still  don't do this  [Music]  they're right to fear me  I've seen Abel  I'm looking at it now  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]